[Applaudissements]
il y à des imperfections plus agréables
que d'autres moi aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous parler d'une
imperfection difficile a avoué le genre
que vous n'allez pas dire à votre grande
tante à noël parce que vous savez que
vous allez la mettre mal à l'aise j'ai
été malheureuse profondément le genre de
malheur de tristesse qui vous prend au
fond du ventre pendant plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines j'ai été malheureuse
malgré des amis proches de moi
malgré des études que beaucoup envient
une famille qui m'aiment et un amoureux
formidable et croyez moi ça aurait été
bien plus facile de vous dire je me
sentais seul je n'aime pas ce que je
fais je ne trouvent pas de stage parce
que c'est plus facile c'est plus commun
comment perfection aujourd'hui l'une des
choses pour lesquelles on nous met le
plus la pression c'est le bonheur
l'épanouissement le haut de la montagne
être heureux c'est devenu à mon sens la
norme sociale la plus discriminante
on peut dire je suis au chômage
je suis célibataire je n'aime pas ce que
je fais mes dires je suis malheureux ça
c'est une imperfection qui provoque de
la peur qui provoque de la gêne vous
vous imaginez répondre à quelqu'un qui
vous demandent poliment si ça va non non
en ce moment ça ne va pas je suis
malheureuse pourtant être malheureux
avoir mille idées négatives qui se
bousculent dans nos têtes c'est normal
ce n'est pas rare d'être confrontés à
cela
n'écoutez pas les gens qui vous disent
qu'ils sont stables écoutez plutôt le
discours de rage à youtube heures qui
tenait la chaîne haute aux disciples
nous dire c'est le bordel dans la tête
de
le monde même les plus sûrs d'eux les
plus déterminés les plus impassible se
pose des questions
vous n'êtes pas tout seul être perdu
c'est une idée assez rassurantes je
trouve mais surtout à ses vraies elles
nous aident à décomplexer le fait que
parfois même quand tout va bien c'est
compliqué parce que nous sommes
compliqués nous sommes complexe donc ça
me paraît normal que parfois ça soit
compliqué on a cette image de la
perfection un peu lisse en tête qui
ressemble à une liste de courses amour
tchèque amis tchèques et tu tchèque il
ya pas mal de cases à cocher et on
s'imagine un peu que quand on a à cocher
tout ou partie des cases alors ça ira on
sera heureux ça aura fonctionné
la vérité c'est que nous sommes
infiniment plus complexe que cette
perfection là nous sommes bien plus
multiples disant plus plurielle vient
plus multiforme qu'un bonheur en forme
de liste de courses
nous sommes bien moins statique qu une
check list
et c'est vrai je pense que parfois ça
nous fait peur de se rendre compte que
notre bonheur il ne rentre pas dans
notre this case parce que nous sommes
plus grand plus contradictoires plus
paradoxaux efficace on veut tout et on a
raison on veut un travail challengeant
pouvoir voyager pouvoir créer avoir du
temps pour soi être aimé tous en aimant
une seule personne on a des paradoxe
ambulant des contradictions vivante
alors oui parfois c'est compliqué mais
ça nous rend riche
ça nous permet de prendre des détours de
jolis chemins de nouvelles voies ses
contradictions internes
ce ne sont pas simplement donné au
cerveau ce sont aussi des possibilité
d'explorer de nouvelles versions de nous
mêmes alors on peut dire qu être
malheureux c'est une imperfection
moi je trouve que ça n'a pas de sens
parce que ça nous correspond à tous et
surtout je trouve que cette imperfection
on peut la regarder autrement et la robe
fructueuse la rendre belle quand je suis
entrée en maternelle
au bout de quelques semaines la
maîtresse a fait venir mes parents à
l'école parce qu'elle pensait que
j'étais autiste je ne parlais à aucun
autre enfant
mes parents m'ont alors demandé médiane
pourquoi tu ne parles pas aux autres
enfants tu sais parler et je leur ai
répondu que souvent la maîtresse disait
qu'elle allait punir les enfants qui
parlait du coup je ne parlait jamais à
personne pour respecter les règles plus
tard adolescente j'ai passé plus d'une
demi-journée à avoir la nausée à la
simple idée de rencontrer la mère de mon
petit copain vous dit peut-être
maintenant ok en fait cette fille c'est
une malade de la conformité et des
règles et elle est extrêmement timide et
vous avez un peu raison ce sont de vrais
défauts mais une fois que je les ai dit
une fois que je vous en parle que je
suis capable de les exprimer ses défauts
ce ne sont plus les imperfections
ce sont des bases de travail une fois
que j'en ai pris conscience je suis
capable de construire dessus et de ne
plus être une viennent de 4 ans timide à
l'extrême mais une dizaine de 22 ans
capable de parler fort en public
ce que je veux dire c'est que prendre
conscience des choses même quand c'est
négatif
même quand il s'agit d'être malheureux
ce n'est pas à vous et une imperfection
c'est la dépasser c'est aller au delà
alors on peut toujours dire quatre
malheureux c'est une imperfection
moi je pense que c'est une difficulté
normale de gens normaux qui font face à
la vie et surtout je pense que cette
difficulté on peut la saisir pour
devenir une opportunité une possibilité
une potentialité d'aller mieux d'avancer
de progresser
alors quand vous pensez à des défauts
inavouable pour vous avez peur donc vous
avez honte
vous pouvez les retourner les éclairer
parce que les montrer en plein jour ça
fait toujours moins peur et surtout ça
vous donne la possibilité de désamorcer
ces peurs et d'avancer d'aller de
l'avant et comment on fait ça comment on
passe d'être malheureux d'aller mal à
pouvoir passer à l'action pour moi la
première chose c'est qu'il faut
reconnaître qu'on est malheureux et
qu'on ne va pas bien ensuite il faut
comprendre que le malheur ce n'est pas
le problème est que ce n'est donc pas le
malheur qu'il faut galère le malheur
c'est le symptôme quand vous il ya une
blessure plus profondes et essai de
cette blessure l'a dont on veut
s'occuper
bien sûr ça peut prendre du temps
d'identifier en vous ce qui est cassé ce
qui est fragile ce qui vous inquiète
mais ce temps là il est important il est
important parce que vos doutes vos
interrogations
vos questions ne s'ennuieront pas seul
vous pouvez travailler 70 heures par
semaine vous occuper l'esprit vous
efforcer de sourire ça sera toujours là
quelque part
alors plutôt que de faire ça je vous
propose d'exprimer votre malheur il ya
mille moyens de le faire vous pouvez
aller voir un psy pouvez en parler à des
amis
vous pouvez écrire vous vous enregistrez
vous pouvez danser votre malheur mais en
tout cas exprimé le jusqu'à aller au
fond des choses
jusqu'à ce que vous n'ayez plus rien à
en dire
alors vous saurez reconnaître votre
malheur et surtout reconnaître sa source
moi par exemple j'ai été malheureuse
parce que je ne savais pas qui j'avais
envie d'être ni ce que je voulais faire
de ma vie mais une fois que j'ai pu
poser des mots sur mon malheur mon
malheur ça n'était plus une brume
obscures qui m'entouraient c'est devenu
une cible à dégommer
et croyez moi c'est bien plus facile
d'apprendre
tiré peu d'apprendre à dissiper du
brouillard la première chose qu'on peut
faire pour dégommer cette cible c'est de
se faire aider parce que ce n'est pas
parce que votre malheur vous concerne
vous tout seul que vous devez vous en
occupez vous tout seul
l'idée est assez simple la faire
admettre à son ego ça l'est un peu moins
pourtant savoir reconnaître lorsqu'on a
besoin d' aide
ça n'est pas un aveu de faiblesse c'est
une preuve de force de lucidité et de
détermination
aujourd'hui les ressources des moyens
les outils qu'on a à notre disposition
pour surmonter nos difficultés
ils sont multiples presque infinies bien
sûr on peut aller consulter un
psychologue mais maintenant il ya plein
de nouvelles méthodes qui s'offrent à
nous la méditation la pleine conscience
la sophrologie le yoga mille voie de
développement personnel je sais que ça
peut faire peur de souffrir à d'autres
et de s'ouvrir à d'autres méthodes pour
surmonter les difficultés et avancer je
le sais parce que moi j'ai eu très peur
et j'ai été très réticente
pourtant aujourd'hui je fais un peu
partie de ces gens qu'on met dans une
case de bobo alternatifs parce qu'ils se
posent des questions bizarres
cette case là en face de ce que ça m'a
apporté
ça ne vaut rien ça ne vaut rien du tout
alors mon premier conseil c'est
d'essayer essayer de nouvelles méthodes
vous en trouverez forcément une qui vous
parlera qui vous correspondra et qui
vous aidera à avancer et à aller mieux
mon deuxième conseil c'est de vous faire
confiance pour de nouvelles choses je
pense qu'on a tous envie d'explorer le
monde de découvrir de se lancer dans une
nouvelle activité mais forcément c'est
difficile et c'est mille fois plus
difficile quand on est malheureux
et pourtant c'est pile le moment de le
faire c'est exactement cet instant là
que vous pouvez saisir pour explorer
différentes facettes de vous-même comme
j'évoquais tout à l'heure je pense qu'on
est tous profondément pluriel un
boulanger il n'est pas que boulanger
il est peut être boulanger est fan
d'astrophysique
peut-être que quand il est triste il
regarde les étoiles et il invente des
aventures aux constellations qu'ils
regardent et peut-être que ça l'aide et
je pense vraiment qu'on est un peu tous
comme ce boulanger simplement c'est plus
facile c'est plus rassurant de ne
montrer que la facette que les autres
connaissent déjà
pourtant assumer nos paradoxes nos
contradictions nos différences quand on
va mal c'est pouvoir faire le constat
qu'on peut mettre ce qu'on veut sur
notre chemin
on peut mettre mille possibilités qui à
la base n'y était pas et ce constat là
quand on va mal il est extrêmement
rassurant
mon dernier conseil qui est assez lié
avec cette idée de pouvoir explorer
mille possibilités c'est de minimiser
votre identité
c'est une idée que j'emprunte à paul
graham qui a été vulgarisée par rage le
youtuber que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
il nous dit minimiser votre identité
ça vous permettra de ne pas perdre en
intelligence et moi je pense que ça vous
permettra également de gagner en liberté
si aujourd'hui je vous dis je suis
flexitariens je suis protestante et je
suis de droite
parfaitement faux mais peu importe vous
allez vous faire une image assez précise
de moi et vous allez lire mes actions
mais décision mais pensez à travers ce
spectre mais moi aussi moi aussi je vais
me contraindre un peu à rentrer même
inconsciemment dans les images
collective associés à des étiquettes que
moi même je me suis collé pourtant ces
étiquettes
elles seront toujours moins fines que
moi
les mille versions de moi-même que
j'aurais pu explorer alors le conseil
que j'ai pour vous c'est de préférer
passer votre temps à explorer tout ce
que vous êtes plutôt qu'à essayer de le
définir
finalement ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que je ne sais toujours pas ce que
je veux faire de ma vie ni qui j'ai
envie d'être et que parfois ça me rend
encore malheureuse en revanche
maintenant je sais de reconnaître je
sais m'en sortir je sais que ça n'est
pas grave
et je sais que j'ai beaucoup pas en
apprendre j'ai été malheureuse et
j'espère que ça vous arrivera tous un
jour merci
[Applaudissements]